good morning everyone this is the new
hampshire house committee on election we
have today scheduled public hearings
followed by executive session there will
be a short break between public hearings
and the executive session and of course
exactly when that starts and ends
depends on what time it is
we are going to start with the hearing
on house bill 1149 but before we do that
i ask that you rise and join me in a
pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
thank you everyone
first matter on our agenda this morning
is hb 1149 this is relative to the
number of names required for nomination
by nomination papers and with us to
introduce the bill to the committee is
the sponsor representative craig
representative craig welcome to election
law
good morning
thank you madam chair good morning
members of the committee
for those of you who i have not had the
fortune to meet yet my name is kevin
craig i represent coast county district
4 which is the towns of lancaster and
dalton and the
unincorporated place of kilkini
so
to be
if you will give me one moment
my prepared remarks are safely in my new
notebook right next to the door where i
won't forget them but i do have a copy
so
running for office in new hampshire is
famously easy we have a volunteer
legislature essentially volunteer
as you all know and thank you all for
giving your time and service to the
people of our state
nominations and elections are governed
by rsa chapter 655 which i'm sure the
members of this committee know better
than i do
since you deal with it exclusively
each of us here today as members of the
two
currently recognized parties
fill out a simple form and pay two
dollars that's town hall or city hall
it's a trivial process for anyone who is
registered as a member of one of the two
major parties before the filing deadline
closes
and for those who aren't members of one
of the two currently recognized parties
it is more complicated they must file
nomination papers which means a petition
drive
currently rsa 655 colon 42 requires that
150 qualified voters sign a nomination
paper nominating a candidate for state
representative or a county office
executing papers from throughout the
state each of those must be on a
separate sheet of paper and must be
verifiable and verified in order to be
counted
to attain party ballot access and avoid
the nomination paper process rsa 655
colon 42 roman numeral 3
requires 3 percent of voters in the most
recent statewide election meaning the
total votes cast for
president u.s senator or governor
this limits access to the minority of
potential candidates who are registered
members of a major party
it's a disadvantage to those in rural
areas that are less densely populated
and i will note that with the coming
redistricting coast county loses a
representative we are the graphical
county and the least
populous
one of the proposed districts will be
almost half of the
geographical area of coast county
putting it
almost on a par with a couple of our
smaller counties yet we'll have only one
representative
our new hampshire constitution in part
the first article 11 states every
inhabitant of the state having the
proper qualifications
has equal right to be elected into
office
part 2 article 3 states that we the
legislature have an obligation to
prevent monopolies by any persons or
associations
limiting ballot access is a violation of
our fundamental sense of fairness
our
state motto of seeking
fair access and competition fair
competition in all things and avoiding
monopoly
and let me say just for the record i'm
not presenting this on behalf of any
party
i have no plans to run for any party
except the one of which i'm currently a
member
i have not coordinated with any other
party officials
on fully
that i ask that you give it favorable
consideration and i will take any
questions
i have a question oh thank you
representative prudhomme o'brien thank
you for taking my question can you tell
me a little bit about why you chose
to reduce it by
two-thirds
exactly
in all of the races so i did cut it uh
to one-third of the current numbers
because that is a level that they have
been at previously
every time that
we've had
an election that results in a
third party gaining status
the numbers get changed
and that has gone off and on throughout
the years the numbers have been higher
they've been lower
but i think this is a
and
readily attainable goal for any
candidate who is not a member of the
major two parties
and
gives
much better access and is more fair
further questions from committee
follow-up to that representative craig
could you tell me when this number
changed to the current number and what
the number was before it became what's
currently in statute uh i do not have it
with me as i said i left my notes uh
the the the list of changes is in the
rsas is listed online uh the the dates
that it's changed right the dates that
which are sort of difficult to follow
right so you know so you don't know
whether your your decision to go to one
third has any actual relation to any
prior amount in this statute uh i have
seen the numbers referenced before
okay
thank you further questions from the
committee
i'm not seeing any thank you thank you
also signed up to speak to this bill is
welcome back representative branch
hello members of the election law
committee
for the record my name is representative
tony lebranch and i represent the town
of amherst
i come before you today to in support of
house bill 1149 which lowers ballot
access requirements for independent and
third party candidates
this bill simply gives granite staters
more choice when it comes to voting this
makes sense in new hampshire as nearly
one third of our voters identify as
independents
what i often hear from constituents is
that people are tired
of the two-party system and they want
more options
people are tired of voting for the
this along with other electoral reforms
such as ranked choice voting would
increase participation in our democracy
and increase representation and with
that i ask that the committee passed
this bill with an odd pass
recommendation
representative you mentioned that you
thought that this would increase
participation do you have anything from
any other states or this state what
representative craig seemed to indicate
that these numbers have changed before
um that led to an increase in pop in
participation
thank you for the question
uh i would say uh a lot of the evidence
is mostly uh members of third parties in
the state who
when it comes to election season they're
not able to vote for a candidate that
they
do support um oftentimes they do not
agree with both parties uh so they just
do not go out and vote because they are
not represented on the ballot and they
do not have an opportunity to speak on
the ballot as writing candidates
statistically have a very low chance of
winning thank you
i'm seeing none thank you for coming
also signed up to speak on 11 49 is
katie gargano from the secretary of
welcome
is the red light on
there you go thank you
good morning madam chair and members of
the election law committee my name is
katie gargano and i'm representing the
secretary of state's office on house
bill 1149
the secretary of state's office opposes
this bill
the bill is lowering the requirements
for nomination by nomination papers by
two-thirds to get your name on the
general election ballot
the imposed numbers are not fair to the
primary candidates who have gone through
the full primary process to get the full
support of the voters to be on the
ballot
we foresee lowering these numbers
the requirements would add clutter to
the general ballot and the existing
requirements in the law for nominations
by nominating papers is a reasonable
amount and has been in place for a
number of years dating back to 1979
i i did some research in those big law
thank you representative tarosian
thank you madam chair thank you ma'am
for taking the question
so when it was on the number required
was last changed do you know what the
numbers were back then prior to the
the current uh number for each office
we did not find a date when the numbers
were ever changed
the
the books go back to 1979 when the
codification occurred and those numbers
quick quick follow-up follow-up so so as
far as you can tell then the numbers
have not changed from 1979 to present
follow up to that if you know there was
a reference made in earlier testimony
that this number changes depending on
whether a third party
is successful on getting on the ballot i
thought i had heard that
as being a trigger mechanism for this
number are you aware of that and if so
what is that because there was recently
a third party candidate on the ballot
right i think that that person was
thinking of the requirement
in a general election ballot if they get
a certain number of votes then the party
gets to stay
on the ballot and i it's
currently four percent
i believe it's four percent currently
um and i believe there's another bill
later on today that's asking to lower
that right okay thank you for that
clarification further questions from
committee members
i'm not seeing any and that is the last
speaker i have signed up if
representative teroznian could go get
the blue sheet
that would be terrific
uh there was remote testimony
on this just as a reminder if you're
watching or even here in the room you
can get on the
the general court website and go to
particular bills and submit testimony
online
by
submitting a pdf or some other
attachment which will then
go into the official docket for this
file
you can also just sign up whether you're
in favor or opposed and as to remote
testimony in favor or opposed
as of when the sign up stopped which is
early in the morning on the day of the
hearing there were nine people in
you also have the opportunity to sign up
in person
here at the lob when these hearings
occurred and we've had two persons sign
up today in favor of the bill
and no one else has signed up
seeing no further questions or anyone
requesting to speak on 11 49 i'm going
to close the hearing on 11 up
on 11 49 and we will open the hearing on
the next bill scheduled for 9 45 which
is hb 1166
hb 1166 requires certain parties certain
voters to declare a party affiliation
prior to a state primary election and
requires candidates to be members of
political parties for a certain amount
of time prior to election and which in
which such candidates uh seek election
and we have with us today to introduce
the bill i believe representative love
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the uh the election law committee uh
for the record my name is uh
representative david love i represent uh
rockingham county six which is derry and
uh this bill of
i
the idea came uh as a result of a real
contentious special election uh that we
had uh just recently in derry for a
state rep candidate uh state rep seat
and uh you know the
the uh the deception that was uh was
used in that uh that election
i don't think it's what our founders
intended when uh when we put put
together our election laws
um
currently in statute uh
the uh the parties are allowed to uh
dictate if they want to close the
election but there's uh
there's no uh
there's nothing in statute as far as uh
when somebody has to declare and this
bill will do that
um
i i do have an amendment that uh just
came through uh
that uh it will be uh
it will strike uh
the uh the requirement to uh
to be a party member for six months
before you run for office
and it will also add uh it's just for
federal and uh not it's not for federal
so state in in city elections
um
like i said uh
you know the the the uh the deception
that's being practiced uh you know
there's dozens of uh of social media
posts you know let's all go undeclared
and then grab it grab grab republican
ballots and and mess with their election
and mess with their primaries uh you
know like i said i i don't think you
know it's what i i found this one we
want we're clean fair and and
you know and you know no deception in
our in our elections would be uh the the
best
you know the best um way of doing it and
uh i'd like to see that and uh that's
thank you representative love um
and i have just been handed an amendment
to hb 1166 does everybody over there
have it
you you all have it
it might have been done in two
two different amendments there was quite
a few quite a bit of paper i
just got it just as a rule committee
members you will not go passing out
paperwork until it comes through this
chair first because we end up with too
many papers flying around and i've just
heard from the speaker that there might
be another amendment so i have
one amendment in my hand zero four seven
seven it
right i know so it is two pages so i'm
going to pass it out
and um
ask that somehow we get to
representative ward over there in the
other land um and if there are any
extras then it can go on the table
representative love do you have a copy
it all came down so fast that
all right so why don't we all take a
moment to look at the amendment
all right so just as everybody looks at
it
this amendment changes paragraph what is
now paragraph three on page one of the
original bill if you go to line 27 on
the original bill
this amendment adds
an additional sentence that says the
requirements
of this paragraph shall not apply to
which my recollection is representative
love presented
when he spoke to what he intended the
with the amendment in hand does anybody
have any questions to representative
love
representative mcdonald
good morning representative love morning
um i'm familiar with what you're
referring to in the recent special
election in derry as you know i was i
was involved with that with you and
representative nelson
and i was delighted with the outcome all
the way through
and recognized the problem you're
neither the republican party nor the
democratic party currently has a
majority of voters in new hampshire much
as
both of us would like to have a majority
of voters we don't
undeclared voters are the lightest
voting bloc in the state of new
hampshire and they take both republican
and democratic ballots and primaries
there's been a traditional concern as to
how undeclared voters would react
if they were restricted in terms of
being able to do that is that something
you've taken into consideration at all
yes i have i've talked to talk to
chairman stepanek about it and
you know and people involved with a 603
alliance and what have you when uh you
know uh it's a problem that's going to
get worse uh you know it's uh it's uh
like i said there was you know a dozen
maybe 20 20 different posts on facebook
about let's do this and mess with it uh
you know it uh it just lends to to you
know deception in elections and i don't
think it's any anything that any of us
want and uh you know once once people
understand that they have to 120 days
out and that's a negotiable thing i
i just don't want to change that you
know three seconds before they grab a
ballot
um
you know um i uh
i think we
we've got a guard against you know
deception and lies
follow up madam chairman follow-up
uh representative love you said that
there was talk about messing with
elections on social media did they
indicate
that they were just going to mess with
republican elections or both parties
that they were
known
known progressives in derry they belong
to the the dairy progressive page okay
we're gonna stop this
all right okay
if there is something specific that you
want the committee to consider in
regards to social media postings
then i want you to
um produce it
and if we're saying it's a problem for
both parties i want examples of both
parties i appreciate that there was
concern in us in a specific election
and i can tell you i have i come from a
republican household in massachusetts
with a father who was chair of the
committee and went to a few inaugural
balls just as a side and stopped working
for the party when they opened up
primaries to undeclared in or i think in
massachusetts they might have called
them independent voters because he said
and this was decades ago
because of concerns that you had so
this is not a practice that just this
state has in regards to undeclared or
independent voters being able to pull
a primary
ticket of any party on the ballot
one two three however many there are are
you aware of any other states that have
undeclared ballots that allow
the choice of a primary ballot that
that have undeclared
voters that require registration in a
party to pull that party's
primary ballot there are 13 states i
okay any other questions is that a i
representative
go ahead sorry i'm not seeing very well
thank you thank you madam chair
um and yeah it was the norm prior to the
19 mid 70s or even 1980s to have quote
what we call closed party primaries i'm
curious about the amendment um that that
sets aside federal offices is that
because the national parties regulate
the primaries for federal office or is
it because
federal election law
regulates that why why is that
uh exception for federal office uh i
believe the federal the federal you know
the national parties do
do
have control over it and i was told that
it it just might put a little put the
first nation primary in jeopardy so um
you know i certainly took that out
further questions representative barry
a question comment just to clarify we
don't allow unaffiliated voters to vote
in primaries we actually do not allow
that when you when you go to pull if you
are unaffiliated voter and you go to
pull a party ballot you register as that
party you pull that ballot and then as
we've discussed in this committee before
you have the opportunity to switch back
to unaffiliated uh so it's this is more
actually directed to representative
meerhead because i do love our
philosophical conversations we do have
close primaries in new hampshire um we
just they operate as if they are
may i call my done it
sure go ahead okay uh you know that
that's
that is the the premise uh but when you
when you can change your party
affiliation three literally three
seconds before you you take a ballot uh
it's not really closed it's not in any
way representative barry was actually
referring to the declaration that it's
made when you do such a change that is
codified enough listen okay i just want
to change the law to you know put a
is there anybody else with the question
for representative
representative ward
uh thank you madam chair thanks for
taking my question you spoke about the
founding fathers and the primary do you
know how candidates were nominated in
the 18th century
you know i don't educate me by the
caucus system primaries came in the late
19th century and early 20th so i don't
think we have a founding father's issue
here
thank you
i was going to try and divert and ask
whether they used rank cho's voting but
any further questions for representative
love
all right thank you very much
representative love also signed up to
speak on house bill 1166
is daniel
healey
welcome back to the election law
committee
daniel healey is from the new hampshire
good morning
members of the committee thank you for
giving me the opportunity to speak
my name is daniel healey i'm a derry
town clerk and i'm here on behalf of the
new hampshire city and town clerks
association as we offer our strong
opposition to this bill
as a town clerk i would like to see as
many eligible voters come out to the
polls and vote as possible
in derry we have 19
253 registered voters of those five
thousand two hundred thirty one are
registered as democrat which is around
twenty seven percent
six thousand seven hundred and fifty
seven are republicans which is thirty
five percent and then we have our
undeclared voters which make up over 37
percent of our voting population
many of our undeclared voters vote in
every election but would rather not have
their friends neighbors or family know
their affiliation so they utilize the
change back table and remain undeclared
on election day this bill would cause
confusion and anger to voters that are
turned away because they didn't make a
selection 120 days prior
i question how if this bill passes
voters will be educated in time to not
disenfranchise them
we should be looking at ways to increase
voter participation and not ways to
suppress it
i would recommend the committee to itl
this bill and leave our primaries the
way that they are
thank you and i'm open to any questions
that is the last
person i have signed up to speak on
house bill 1166 if representative
taurosian could get me the the blue
sheet there was remote testim
testimony that went on in the form of
expressing whether an individual is in
favor or opposed to a bill
that sign up had a total of
80 people signed up four persons in
support of the bill 75 opposed
and one person
neutral i have to admit i wasn't i
um and in regards to the sign up sheet
here today
uh
as to parties who did not speak we had a
total of six individuals
signed up and they were all in favor of
the bill
and with that i'm going to close the
hearing
on
and open the hearing on 1174
1174 is relative to election challenges
this bill
the prime sponsor is representative
i'm sorry yokovovich from hooksett and
and i got you in the right build today
thank you madam chair um
i'm um members of the committee madam
chair i'm representative michael youboys
from hooksett representing merrimack 24
and
here i'm presenting 1174 which is a very
simple bill
it arose
after the discussion with some members
of the committee
it's got to do with the purity of
elections and this
here clarifies where the
challengers the whole challengers can be
positioned
uh this bill brings the uniformity to
towns it says that the poll challengers
can be permitted to stand within six
feet of
ballot counting
areas the hand counted ballots
valves being uncounted and within the
line of sight of any electronic device
which is the
machines
that's all this bill is doing it's not
it's just spelling out the rights of the
challengers and specifying the distance
they can be
positioned at it's not changing anything
else in the
assignment of the challengers the
selection of the challengers
compensation of the challengers anything
else just their location
and this is all this bill is about
uniformity clarity
so every town knows what they are there
to do thank you
thank you questions for the
representative representative terozian
thank you madam chair thank you
representative taking the question does
current law specify um
a distance
presently or there's nothing stated you
know thank you for the question no
nothing stated so this will help thank
you
thank you for further questions no
can you turn your mic on
i'm sorry
on lines four and five and of your uh
bill
are you trying to set up a distinction
between towns that hand count in places
that use machines
that i see six feet for hand count and
all you need is a
straight view
of a ballot machine which could be 100
yards away
thank you for the question it's not the
distinction for towns because within the
same town
hand counting can be done on ballots
that are
that don't fit into the machine that you
know don't look right the they'll be a
mistake in the machine so in the same
town both can be done
um so it's not a distinction for towns
it's just where the challengers need to
be
so with the machine
i think it's good enough because you
you're not going to be reviewing every
ballot
but hand counting you want to be closer
to see
the the because the humans decide
what the ballot says and the machine is
the machine it's just you know you just
want to make sure they go in thank you
so you are setting up a distinction
not
i think uh not between talents but
between the ballots the way the bell is
accounted
okay yes thank you
thank you
any further questions
representative wilhelm
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
was there a specific
issue or incident that happened
thank you for the question i
yeah i can't recall this specific
incident it it it arose over several
different discussions in the
in the last year
representative barry i i can help with
that um tangentially representative
willem um
representative asked me about this bill
it was actually one of the ideas i
propositioned to him um and it to answer
your question that was not directed to
me but was was it wasn't effective you
didn't know it um it actually came out
of the
merrimack town election special
um
that they were counting the ballots
and because of where they set up the
rail
it was so far away you couldn't see what
they were doing um i don't believe there
was anything nefarious let me very clear
about that um but if there was something
to be going on there was no way to know
which one was going into which which
pile um
so that was when
the representative contacted me about
asking me which which sort of um
uh bills i think the committee might
actually have some some tolerance to
passing i said this might be a
reasonable um this might be a reasonable
approach to add some transparency
election without actually interfering
with the operations
but to answer your question it was
merrimack
thank you
seeing none
um thank you for your
presentation of the bill also signed up
for 1174 is diane fisher
good morning madam chair and committee
members uh i did not intend to speak
today i came to be in support of the
bill
however arriving here i've been
motivated i guess as i have so much in
the past i'm from hampstead new
hampshire i've lived in new hampshire
for over 50 years i've always voted i've
always considered myself civic minded
and tried to become educated about the
situations and the votes that i would
cast it is only in the last few years
that i have become much more active
whether it be supporting candidates
running rallies etc i've always been
kind of out there
in the 2020 election it was the first
time and i'm a little bit sorry to say
that i volunteered as a poll watcher
why did i do that
there was such an undercurrent of
feeling i didn't quite have my finger on
the pulse of it but i was
nervous i wasn't confident i felt some
angst going on and some things happening
in my town of hampstead that i couldn't
believe
and i thought you know i don't want to
worry about this i want to make sure i
want to assure that everybody's vote and
my vote as well are counted and how can
i sit back and complain about something
if i am not there if i do not
you know lend a hand more than handing
outside standing there with with the
signs as i usually did and everything
else i also was privileged to be allowed
to be in pembroke and i went there day
after day after day as as many others
did that were allowed to witness the
situation there and very impressed with
the people that were doing the hand
counting etc but also aware of the same
things that i was witnessing and seeing
in different areas that the visibility
is not always there
it wasn't that we were denied it
ultimately you know to that feeling but
we had to ask could you please move
could we please see could we please take
a camera shot at this that or the other
thing it doesn't seem plausible that you
should have to do that it should be very
obvious as to your question about where
did
uh you know did something arise that
brought forth the need for this that
that we
have a shorter distance or be able to
see i don't even think it's important
that anything had to happen in merrimack
it's unfortunate if it did but this is
about in my standard my feeling about
this is to prevent more division more
angst you know and the uniformity i like
that word uniformity across the state so
that everybody feels the same way you
don't want to feel that you have to move
or say excuse me or try to feel or
realize as i did at times that i could
not see i didn't have full access
it isn't about the change it isn't about
the party but i think anyone and i
respect so much you all you know that
you have done and dedicated your life to
being in a situation where you help this
state to be what it is we have elections
whether we are a democrat a republican
independent whatever our position we
want to be confident that we have felt
and exposed ourselves to the truth that
we align ourselves with a president or a
vice president or our secretary of state
or whoever it might be that was duly
elected and we are confident in that do
we not see and i believe it granted it's
just my opinion but i s i think truly in
my heart and soul that if you asked
every citizen of the united states who
may be voted in the 2020 collect
election or might be in the future do
you trust the elections do you trust the
process and whether they be a democrat a
republican an independent whatever
i really feel at this time in our nation
most everyone would say no
the democrats think the republicans are
sneaky the republicans don't trust this
independence who knows what it is but
this is something we can do it is one
small step that we can take it to me is
a no-brainer who would not want you to
be a little bit closer to the action to
see so you can go back to your
constituents your people or your
neighbors and say yep it was okay from
everything i saw
i have one more thing to say i am so
tired of a word that i am so guilty of
using
it just
it brings tears to my eyes that the word
that i have used the most and i'm trying
not to do it but here it is
unbelievable
my husband passed away i'm a widow and i
often say if he came back and i spoke to
him and told him what was going on now
in this current world that we sit in he
would say
it can't be
it's unbelievable i speak to my friends
and they say can you believe what
happened can you see can you whatever
unbelievable has become the word
and i want believable to become the
words i implore you i am passionate i
love my country i have four children i
have eight grandchildren i have every
generation from the civil war letters
from people in my family i did not serve
and i'm not proud of that but i am
trying to serve my nation my country my
state now by speaking to the sanity
to bring it back the common sense the
belief in our system and i pray that you
will listen to that and i thank you so
much i didn't mean to go on for such a
length of time but i speak from my heart
didn't have any notes no foam no
technology
just from my heart and i thank you thank
you
the next person signed up to speak on
good morning good morning
thank you for the opportunity to speak
and i have to tell you
that is a tough act to follow
i agree with everything that she said
and i just want to add a couple things
to that
i agree this is not
a partisan issue this is not republicans
or democrats i have talked
to many on both sides of the line and
everybody has echoed to me their
concerns for election integrity
and i've had conversations about
concerns about what happened in windham
not just in 2020 but
for many many many elections
we have
our moderators
set up
the table where they count
the votes on ballots
that either can't go through the
machines or the military you acaba
ballots
and they do that 40 to 50 feet away from
any meaningful observation
and that's unacceptable
they will deny that they do this but it
happens every single election and it's
got to stop
now i'm not saying that they're doing
anything wrong i'm not saying that
there's any impropriety there
but i don't know and what happened after
november 3rd 2020
with the wyndham election and all the
all of the issues there were laws that
were violated there were procedures that
were violated
and we can't have questions about our
elections it's unacceptable
i've had former i've had many
conversations with former secretary of
state bill gardner
and he agrees
and
you know it's important
that both parties be represented
when those votes are being counted
that's the only way to ensure
transparency it's the only way
to alleviate any potential questions
after the fact
so that when they if it not if because
they will arise you want to be able to
have everybody represented
with people there who actually saw what
took place and they can and they can
quell down
any questions
and say you know everything was done on
the other thing that i just want to
point out is when i first read this bill
uh so within standing within six feet i
think is very very very important
uh the other thing that's in here is the
line of sight of the electronic ballot
counting devices
now i don't think that has been an issue
for
people across the state i don't know
that for a fact but i do know in other
states
there was ballot there was counting of
ballots that were going on
where they
they were doing that in a separate room
they actually put up
and blocked windows where people could
see in the other rooms i don't think
that's happened in in this state but it
has happened in others and if it can
happen there we want to make sure that
it cannot happen here so i support that
as well
thank you very much for listening to my
testimony this is a very important bill
thank you mr eyring questions from
i'm not representative ward
thank you madam chair just thank thank
you for taking my question i was just
curious
in your case and maybe that of the
previous witness whether you've ever
considered working as an election
official in your town i've actually put
my name in this year to uh to hopefully
be one of the people selected to be
behind the rail
and i hope that this is passed so that
we can make sure that
um
the elections are done properly
good for you thank you thank you too
representative muirhead thank you madam
chair
is there anything that prevents
election officials from
allowing people to be within six feet of
hand count right now yeah there there's
there's limitations as to who can be
but when i spoke with secretary gardner
his
his feeling was that there's no reason
why those tables can't be moved up to
the rail so even though the law says you
can't be behind the rail
those tables are set up where they're
counting it's not just 40 or 50 feet
away they have the machine set up in
front of the table you can't see
and and when you take into consideration
with what happened on november 3rd 2020
the machines
miscounted the votes for
all four republicans and this again i'm
just using this as an example
i believe in other towns that that
democrats lost votes in windham
republicans lost votes on election day
there was
about 300 votes give or take three votes
for each of the four
candidates but one of the candidates
gained 99 votes
that could be a machine issue
but you don't know it raises questions
we don't want those questions we're the
first in the nation primary we want to
make sure that anybody who wants to take
that privilege away from our state
is not is not doing so with any basis to
any further questions for ken for mr
eyring
seeing none thank you
that is the last person i have signed up
to speak on 1174.
um in regards to
1174 there was remote testimony
51 people signed signed up in support of
it 135 people signed up opposed to it
and we had
three four people signed up in favor of
it i'm going to close the hearing on hb
and open the last hearing of our morning
hb 1197 relative to the definition of
party
for election purposes representative
craig welcome back to the table and
welcome to introduce your bill thank you
uh madam chair i'll skip the
introductions i hope no one has
hb 1197 covers a slightly different area
from 1149 that we discussed earlier
and
my arguments are the same
covering the same material this simply
changes the deficit definition of party
from four percent to one percent i would
like to clarify uh
that i do not believe and i hope i did
not imply that there is any kind of an
automatic trigger
uh
based on the performance of a of a third
party i just want to make it clear that
i could be incorrect the secretary of
state's office
thinks the law hasn't changed since 1979
i will
accept their
historical research on that
but i do remember
having heard in the past
that
changes to the percentages and number of
nomination required
has
varied by legislation
depending on the performance of third
parties so i just want to make it clear
that i do not believe that there is any
automatic trigger thank you for that
clarification i probably missed all
right
so with that i know that there's going
to be
an amendment
from representative lebranch i have
reviewed it
and
i don't want to steal any of his thunder
on that but i do support his change it
is more inclusive than what
my original bill is
i will take any questions
questions for representative craig
i'm not seeing any thank you
also signed up to speak on 1197 is
and i will give you the amendment
thank
here pass them down
joe
matt and i'll give you one for
representative craig
okay representative lebranch thank you
good morning again members of the house
election law committee for the record my
name is representative tony the branch
and i represent the town of amherst
i also want to be
very clear
on this bill and the previous one i
testified on is that
as the uh one of the two independents in
this house i want to be
very clear that i'm not running for
reelection this is not for me
this is truly what i believe is the
right thing to do
i'm not
like i said i'm not running again so
this would not apply to me anyways so
with that i come before you today to in
support of house bill 1197 which lowers
the requirements to be considered an
official party
in new hampshire
i also came with the amendment this
amendment improves the bill it increases
the ways in which a party can be
qualified as an official party and enjoy
ballot access that comes with it
this legislation and the amendment i
brought forward is an amazing step to
giving the people more choice when it
comes to election season my constituents
as well as voters across the state and
country are tired of the new parties and
want change and the opportunity to
choose others currently in new
hampshire from my understanding is one
of the worst states when it comes to
and i will also share that this is one
of the
first bills that the independent caucus
officially endorses
and with that i ask that you
pass this bill with an ought to pass
recommendation uh ought to pass with
amendment i guess i should say
and with that i can take any questions
representative ward thank you
thank you madam chair thanks for taking
my question i just wondered if you could
shed some light on how you define
the def uh thank you for the question do
you mean the definition of a party or
political organization like a pac
currently uh it says parties should also
include any political organization
uh i believe that's a term already used
under existing law and the amendment
would simply just expand that to include
the one difference in in my amendment is
it's adding president of the united
states to one of the elections that is
used to
reach that one percent threshold in the
bill and also adding that section that
uh if there is a member of the general
court that is uh
of another party from the other two that
it would be an official uh party under
question representative lane
thank you thank you representative
branch um
so would independent then be a party
since there's i mean assuming that you
were running so that's a political
organization and would be a party under
this statute i'm just trying to
understand it uh
currently i'm registered thank you for
the question currently i'm registered as
unaffiliated i would remain unaffiliated
and that is not considered a party
okay thank you
representative prudhomme o'brien
thank you
i'm gonna work on this a little bit
excuse me
so uh if this were to pass and you or i
were to
become members of a
party such as the rent is too dang high
party tomorrow um
then that would become a recognized
political party in this state
that is correct uh
the most recent example i can think of
is the libertarian party of new
hampshire when a few representatives a
few terms ago
switched to libertarian at the time it
was a recognized party they had the
option to uh become members of that
party um
but that would make it so that they
could continue their ballot access and
official party status uh and other
parties that could eventually come from
this such as the forward party or
progressive party of new hampshire
further questions representative barry
so this bill would
if somebody changed parties while they
were in office so a republican became a
libertarian then the libertarians would
automatically have ballots access
statewide that's correct may have a
follow-up madam chairman
so
isn't it disingenuous for someone to run
as a party and they get elected and then
change parties
because this would encourage that this
would encourage somebody hypothetically
running as let's say a democrat
and then getting elected and then
becoming a forward progressive whatever
isn't that kind of dis are we
encouraging people to be kind of
disingenuous to the to the voters by
basically trojan horsing as a different
party
thank you for the question i would say
that current statue actually encourages
it as
we saw you have to run as either a
democrat or a republican to get elected
and i don't believe that party
affiliation is something that anybody
takes lightly it is
part of our fundamental identity as
human beings you know
people who are unaffiliated are
unaffiliated for a reason people who
identify as democrats identify as
democrats for a reason uh and i believe
that everybody should have an
opportunity to affiliate with them
the party that they truly identify with
i don't believe that libertarians should
be forced to be part of the republican
party and run as republicans and
keep that affiliation i believe
everybody should be true to themselves
and identify with whatever party that
they truly believe in
and i don't believe it's disingenuous to
the voters
to switch parties i believe that's just
a reality of the political situation
here in new hampshire
representative muirhood
why
if there were one member of the general
court who identified as unaffiliated why
wouldn't the label unaffiliated become a
party
that shows up on the ballot in the
general election thank you for the
question uh unaffiliated i believe by
definition means lacking of a party you
are not identifying with any party uh
when you register to vote if you leave
that section of the voter registration
form blank you will just automatically
be considered unaffiliated
thank you thank you further question
could i have a follow-up question
um
madam sheriff yes thank you
if if someone were to identify
affirmatively as an independent and not
and then the word independent would
appear on our general election ballots
as a separate party what would prevent
30 or 40 different candidates for from
thank you for the question i'm not sure
i understand that distinction you're
making but i will speak a little bit to
the uh fact of being an independent and
would that be considered a party uh
as many of you probably do not know
other countries do have independent
coalitions where
to meet ballot access requirements
independents form a coalition
they probably have nothing in common
when it comes to political ideology or
platform but
for the ease of access of to the ballot
these independents foreign parties i
know germany the czech republic is also
another one where these independent
parties
they're only parties in the formal sense
that they would get ballot access and it
would make it easier for independents
such as one of my constituents who does
want to run as an independent next year
to be on the ballot
further question
one more i'm sorry to drag this out
madam chair thank you very kindly
i don't really understand what the
screening function would be
that would prevent numerous candidates
from identifying us independents and all
thank you for the question as the
amendment states it is a member of the
general court that must change their
party affiliation
for it to be identified as a party so it
doesn't have anything to do with any
candidates that will run it says that if
this party were to become officially
recognized they would get a
they would have a state-sponsored
primary and they would be an official
party just like the democratic party
just like the republican party and just
like the libertarian party was in 2018.
thank you madam chairman and good
morning representative lebranch
facilitating the creation of new parties
risk fragmenting the political system
and even lead to a greater challenge in
terms of getting things done policy laws
and so forth being accomplished
thank you for the question uh in
relation to that question i would say
to my previous testimony on previous
bills such as ranked choice voting would
be one option it would be more
representative of the people if we had
multiple political parties to choose
from
that and my partyless proportional
legislation which i introduced to the
legislative administration committee
which is
an electoral system used in almost every
single european democracy where
people
vote for their local candidates and they
also mark on the ballot which party they
prefer and then that legislature is made
proportional to
whatever percentage each party got so uh
i'm saying
this bill in conjunction with ranked
choice voting and other electoral
reforms would not fragment the system
and just lead to a more consensus-based
system where negotiation and cooperation
uh are
paramount and it would lessen the
divisions and hyperpartisanship that we
see in our democracy today
further questions
representative bergeron
thank you madam chair um i guess my
question is a practical one how many
party columns do you think will fit on
an eight and a half by 14 inch ballot
and what happens if 20 or 30 parties are
created by members of the general court
for for an election
thank you for the question uh in my
experience being a member of this body i
not many people have expressed
that they would like to change parties
or form a new party uh
that was not even my intention in
leaving uh my previous party um but i
think realistically we would only see
either one or two
that being the libertarian party of new
hampshire
because they have a track record of
having members switch to that party or
maybe the forward party or maybe a new
progressive party that would come about
but
realistically speaking because of the
current system no ranked choice voting
no proportional representation
these parties
realistically speaking would probably
not have a chance of winning because
that would be vote splitting and vote
splitting is an issue
that i take very seriously which is why
i
endorse the ideas of ranked choice
voting and proportional representation
so that the people of the state the
people of this country should be
represented
just because you're a libertarian and
you have no chance of winning in new
hampshire does not mean that you do not
deserve representation in this body
i know in 2016
the libertarian party i believe
got three to four percent of the vote
in the election which would have
entitled them under a proportional
representation system to about 16 seats
in this legislature yet they only had
three as a result of switching parties
from the republican party
i'm saying that three percent of the
population four percent of the
population goes unrepresented in this
chamber and that they deserve
representation and i don't believe that
is a controversial idea further
questions we might have another speaker
to deal with the ballot issue
thank you representative lebranch also
signed up to speak on this bill is
katie gargano from the secretary of
state's office representative wilhelm we
have a handout that's going out now
here
joe
welcome
all right welcome
good morning everyone again for the
record my name is katie gargano and i'm
representing the secretary of state's
office on house bill 1197
the secretary of state's office opposes
this bill because of the space on the
ballot
lowering the requirement down to one
percent to retain a party column would
require significant changes to our
current ballot layout
i provided you all a copy of the ballot
for the committee to see as an example
as you can see adding another column or
multiple columns to accommodate the many
other parties
would not fit in the portrait position
and may force the ballot to be either
landscape or on multiple pages
this will increase printing costs of the
ballot and would cause and could cause
several formatting issues
we feel that one percent of the votes
cast is not enough support for the party
from our voters
any questions
representative sweeney thank you for
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
we have an amendment in front of us that
amends the proposal to say party shall
also include any political organization
that has at least one member that serves
in the new hampshire general court under
current state law
it's my understanding that the young
republicans the young democrats the
committee to elect house republicans
committee to elect house democrats and
other political groups are noted as
political organizations in new hampshire
i'm not positive
yes
yes for follow-up follow-up if those
organizations are political
organizations under the law would this
amendment not allow
all of those other organizations that
are really subsets of the current
parties to also be on the ballot if a
member chose to run under that ticket
and expand it further even more that
we'd have a name for multiple
organizations as a member you can be a
part of multiple political organizations
just so you know you are in an
impossible situation in a new job
between someone who works for the
parties in the past and in front of and
cannot see the people from your office
who are either nodding their head
in regards to answering or not
so the answer would be yes that would be
true representative sweeney thank you
all right thank you very much i felt i
just i felt terrible for you
i'm good thank you
really trying to get my feet wet here
yeah yeah i i can't wait to hear what
the conversation is on the way back to
the office all right
any other questions representative
mcdonald
just to comment uh
since i'm from londonderry thank you for
your choice of community for this
palette
that's all okay representative murrah
did you have a question all right any
further questions i'm seeing none thank
you very much thank you
all right uh that is the last speaker i
have for 1197. if representative
terezian could get me the the blue sheet
uh
in regards to 1197 people did sign up
online to testify remotely a total
of six signed up in support of the legit
proposed legislation
people signed up in opposition
you now have an amendment and a sample
ballot in regards to your consideration
of this
and one person has signed up in favor of
hb 1197. i'm going to close the hearing
on
h
b 1197
um and
the next thing on our agenda
is executive session
commencing
with
hb 1423
my plan is to go through them
sequentially but if somebody has a
reason to change them because there are
amendments coming or something like that
um i am certainly open to that there was
an amendment i expected to be down here
today that i contacted staff about so
i'm going to have to get that
straightened out so we are taking a
break until
5 of
because i need to track down an
amendment
hey
welcome back everybody this is the house
election law committee we are commencing
about 15 minutes
we are commencing a half an hour late
and i apologize executive session
scheduled for today
the first bill is 14 23 before we take
up 1423
two things
one i have scheduled a meeting for the
so you will be getting a notice of
public hearings and executive session
next thursday the 10th
we will have session on the 17th
there is a rumor we will have session on
the afternoon of the 16th in addition to
the 17th apparently the 16th will be the
state of the state governor formality
thing and we do usually meet after that
i'm not quite sure how that is going to
go given the location issues we have now
but i know for sure session is scheduled
on the 17th so we will not be meeting as
a committee that week given that we have
a session
that day so i wanted to cover that we
you should also have
three amendments in front of you
uh 1 2 10 10
1 to 14 42 we received that at the
public hearing on 1442
and another one to cacr 15.
so
with that
the first bill is 14
14 23
this has to do with a fund relative to
campaign contributions and expenditures
and making an appropriation for it
we had a public hearing on this on
the 19th of january
representative growing madam chair i
move uh that we find this
bill to be itl
is there a second i second that madam
chair uh representative rowan moves
representative sweeney seconds that 1423
is itl representative growing would you
like to speak to your motion
yes i would madam chair
campaign financing has long been a
controversial issue at both state and
federal levels
legislatures and courts have spoken on
the issue over time this has produced
both limits to contribution and
transparency regarding contributions
transparency is provided by the detailed
reporting that is required of all
political candidates and pacs
notwithstanding ads that are from time
to time placed that attack dark money
which i would note are paid for by dark
money
we can from our existing laws determine
where political money comes from in new
hampshire we have contribution limits
for every level of candidates
different candidates in the various
races raise different some different
amounts of money
and that's based on hard work
the amount of contacts the person has
and possibly influence there's no limit
hp 42 1423 provides
a mechanism for public funding of
campaigns
but it does not
provide it does not outlaw or prevent
any of the private campaign financing
that is presently allowed by law
while the mechanism for qualifying for
public financing
is creative in this bit in this
in the approach of this bill it does not
and will not inherently make for cleaner
elections
and finally i would say a major
reason why i oppose this is it just
seems in congress to me
that
the government that
we
would come to
be involved in
would pay for us to get here and that
just does not seem like the right
approach so madam chair i would move
this bill itl
does anybody else want to speak to this
bill representative bergeron
thank you madam chair
um i'm going to vote against the motion
of an expedient to legislate
this is essentially a voluntary program
the candidates have to choose to
participate in it
the public has to choose to donate to
the fund it establishes expenditure
limits for anybody that participates
frankly
there are very few state representatives
that follow the
campaign contribution limits or
expenditure limits that are provided for
them under state law and i'm not so sure
very many people would
elect to participate in this program but
given that it's not requiring state
funding to support it it's all done
voluntarily by both the donors and and
the candidates
i see no reason at all not to support
the concept and
let's see if there are people that buy
into the uh idea of a public funded or
public
private contribution program for funding
our elections
further
um just representative
general question of the committee did
this this bill
it it did what was the cost it did what
was the i don't have it in front of me i
apologize what was that speak to that
this bill um
would fund the the the law with a one
dollar appropriation
so it would create a line item in the
budget for it but would require a
further act of the legislature
to fully fund it so it would not
this system would not become operational
as a virtue as a result of passing this
bill
uh we had four early bills because that
needed to go to other things and i think
this was one of them we had
that's why we had a public hearing on
one yesterday because we needed to get
them out of committee
but the fiscal note um
anybody else representative barry did
you want to
i mean i'll be supporting the motion for
itl because of what you we don't know
how much this is going to cost
and it seems to be a a solution in
search of a problem at this point
but it's
this kind of open-ended
bookend of you know basically writing a
blank check and to representative
gruen's point
it is deeply disturbing that
the people who will be elect that will
be using government funds to get elected
to then run government will then be
making the decisions on how government
runs that's that that seems like not a
good circle or circular system to set up
so that's that is one of the reasons
i'll be supporting itl
anybody else representative muirhead one
quick comment thank you madam chair uh i
i did give
specific cost estimates of it um when in
my testimony but i don't want to get
into those uh details i do appreciate
representative growing's
characterization of the bill as creative
and i look forward to uh i look forward
to continuing our discussions at a
philosophic level about this idea
regardless of what happens today
thank you um i appreciate the reference
to discussions on a philosophical level
i will say it is true the prime sponsor
of this bill representative porter
mentioned that your chair was on a
committee that met over the summer
also president in the room i believe who
participated and my memory fails me
often at this point was olivia's inc
and i think that it is an interesting
concept but i struggle with the
with the problem it is trying to solve
not that there isn't a problem but
having a consensus on what the problem
is
is the problem that we're trying to
solve having can any candidate run
regardless of
financial
independence or ability to finance it
which raises issues as to whether or not
one is financing is trying to get into
the game so to speak for financial
benefit because there's lots of
discussion about people being in
politics for financial benefit
and our campaign contributions really
the wave of where the influence is going
to come from in the future
given that
the reports on the money that went into
the last federal election are that there
was more quote dark money spent and i'll
just say both parties so there's data to
indicate one party got a lot more than
not the other
uh there's more dark money being spent
in addition to that
we now are treading in the line of what
we're seeing in some of our bills here
today which is the private funding of
election
duties whether it is
in pacs that sent much money to help
election officials in certain
communities throughout the country and
that money ended up getting funneled in
a particular way
or whether it is
money being spent to fund election
duties such as audits or other things um
because then you enter into a whole
realm of
sort of a different question so i come
back to what is the problem we are
trying to solve and i will tell you i've
had discussions with john putner who's a
big guy on the campaign finance former
federal official federal elected
official and i have suggested that maybe
federally we should just do it the way
we do in new hampshire it's not really
pay anybody don't give them big pensions
and they won't want to stay long and
we'll get we won't we'll get a whole
different crop of candidates
representative growing did you have
anything else
um i i do have a question my
understanding from the hearing was that
uh the qualification
for receiving state funding was by
raising a certain amount of of uh
independent donations but once that
level of donations had been reached
the
big lump of money so to speak
was going to come from state coffers
right
right the dollars go out you advocate
any further discussion representative
lane
not surprisingly i'm sure to anybody
i'll vote against the itl but i just
i would
i look at this as a campaign finance
reform and i think we all have said we
wanted that
and
part of it is you have to take baby
steps i think and i just saw this as a
good first effort
to do that and it works in other places
and see if it tries to see if it works
in new hampshire and if it doesn't it
doesn't and we've tried i just hate to
see
us say we want to try to solve some
campaign finance issues and then
not do anything
so that would just
be so
well if we passed it it would it would
address one of our other representatives
who's advocating for further definition
on what political expenditures can be
used for because it's got a bet it's got
further detail in it than the statute
does is there any further discussion on
hb 1423
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll for the vote the motion
representative mcdonald yes
that's okay go ahead
representative fruit home o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward
representative alexander
uh yes
representative tarosian yes
representative barry yes
representative growing yes
representative quali
yes
clerk is yes
representative wilhelm
no
representative ward no
representative bergeron no
representative hamer no
representative lane no
representative freitas
representative hamlet no
not yet no no representative griffin yes
sorry
1423 will be reported
uh itl 11 to 9 i'm assuming that there
i'd like to have reports
uh we're not going to make the calendar
obvious
for next
we could make the calendar for the 17th
so
um if we can have those in by monday
or if you really want we could adopt the
old practice that we don't let you out
of the building until they're done
but monday afternoon by email to me so
we could get them
in the calendar for when we can get them
submitted to the clerk's office for
wednesday so it could go in the calendar
to be voted on on the session on the
17th
the next and that will be the same for
all bills we vote on today monday
afternoon with the goal of getting it in
the calendar for
the session we have
the 17th or 16th and 17th
the next bill we have scheduled for
executive session is 1482 for ranked
choice voting for federal and state
offices we have a few
ranchos
ranked choice voting bills this is the
one that establishes such a process for
the largest number of offices
federal and state offices and this was
an early bill
so that is why if you're wondering this
was scheduled and the other ranked
choice voting bills were not scheduled
do i have a motion on 1482
representative terezian thank you madam
chair madam chair i make a motion to
find house bill 1482 fn in exceeding the
legislate
is there a second madam chair i second
that motion seconded by representative
sweeney representative taurosian would
you like to speak to your motion yes
please
so while this is a interesting concept
and i know uh it's being used in maine
and we in fact heard testimony from
i believe the assistant secretary shaden
maine
there are some
problems with it in my opinion that make
it not uh
ready to be uh something i think we
should do here in new hampshire
two of the major items were or or let me
back up and say that
one of the things we heard in testimony
was that this bill would help allow
uh or make it more likely that a third
party candidate could get elected
and in reality uh
in testimony we heard and unquestioning
that in maine it hasn't made a
difference at all so
i don't think this is really going to
change anything there if we were to
adopt it but the other problem i see is
we heard maine that
they have the vote tabulated within a
week
that won't work in new hampshire where
the
the results have to be out
that it has to be completed by the um
day of the election so that that's a
problem
uh further i would say that um
you know i know
one of the arguments was to solve uh
polarity versus a majority vote
well when you have several people on a
ballot and let's face in new hampshire
with the number of
state reps we have you have many
districts where you're voting for
anywhere from
two to ten
state representatives
i am at door knocker when i'm out
campaigning and i found that
a fairly big percentage of people that i
come in contact with
don't even know who their reps are and
quite frankly they're lucky if they can
in a district that has say four or five
reps
really
have a little knowledge on
one or two of them so
i think
you know
if we were to adopt this you're going to
have many people voting you know down
the line for
three choices five choices whatever it
may be
and really not having a good
clear
idea it's kind of like rolling the dice
well let's let's put this person down
for number three i i think it's gonna
dilute
the meaning of of somebody really
doing their due diligence and
in voting for somebody they think will
be the best i think at the end of the
day you should you should vote for the
person or persons
that you believe is going to do the best
job so
for those reasons um
i i think that
the proper thing to do with this bill at
this time is finding speed into uh
legislate thank you
would anybody else like to speak to the
bill
representative bergeron no
i'm i'm going for the red light on the
mic
representative hamlet okay
um hi thank you madam speaker i mean
madam chair sorry
um so to answer
representative trojan's question um
the reason i believe the reason that
maine allows the of
the the you know results uh it gives
them a whole week is because they
allow three days for their
uh election totals to come in whereas in
new hampshire we required to come in the
same day so we could do it much faster
the machines that the secretary of
state's office
would use to tabulate the you know the
ranked choice part
um
would be very quick they would
be very quick so we could probably get
the results the same night if not the
next day
um
i think that's that's my only comment
for now thank you
thank you
does anybody else wish to speak to the
motion on the floor which is itl 1482
seeing none i'm going to ask
i i have uh
some interest in the concept of ranked
choice voting but
mostly for primaries and mostly for
primaries at
uh at the federal level and the major
state race level um
i
certainly would be interested in
some enabling legislation which we have
elsewhere and i just want that
noted that
i think there's there's some benefit to
thank you i think it just came to my
mind that
it sounds
it doesn't sound like something i want
when i have a candidate that i really
want but when i don't really care it
sounds sort of interesting
[Laughter]
and i won't say what races are causing
me to think that all right any further
discussion on this bill
seeing that i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll the motion on the floor
representative mcdonald
yes representative home o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward
okay
representative
yes representative barry yes
representative growing yes
representative quayley
yes
representative ward no
representative murray
no
oh they're not
it's christmas yeah
if anybody is listening to this and
staff can they please verify whether or
not the mics that are at the table
are all working because the lighting
system that usually corresponds with
whether it's on or off
um is not working at a few of our tables
where representative
lane is
seated
all right why don't you continue
uh no
yes
representative your head
no
madam chair
yes
go ahead yes may i change my vote yes
you may she has an
uh my new rule you're it's a for all
all right representative frieda's votes
no
okay so no way it can't be it must be um
oh you just changed it okay
yes 1482 will be reported
itl vote being 12-7 i will assume that
there's going to be a majority and a
minority report
submitted on this bill the next bill we
have scheduled for executive session
today
is 1484 requiring a forensic audit of
the 2020 elections this is also
an early bill hence the scheduling today
this bill
would also established a fund to cover
the costs of conducting the audit
this had a public hearing
yesterday
do i have a motion
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
madam chair i moved to itl this bill and
i would like to speak to that motion
second i second that motion madam chair
thank you representative prudhomme
o'brien you're recognized to speak to
your motion thank you madam chair
uh yesterday we went through some
difficult testimony on this bill
uh testimony that in some cases i found
to be dripping with
a possible violent
innuendo related to inaccurate
assumptions
about my previous votes and those of
other people on this committee and our
motives
despite all of that i put that aside and
tried to focus
solely on the merits of this bill and
the bill starts off with a lot of uh the
words shall rather than may
and
it's we it says that we shall appoint a
third party to conduct the forensic
audit we it shall be completed by
october 1st it shall a report shall be
given detailing the findings
and we're also told that it will be free
to taxpayers due to private donations
but with the word shell if we were to
pass this bill
we have to do it
and if the money is not raised then
that's just a wish the private donation
and the fact that this would be free
wouldn't wouldn't
then be happening
and i think that's a risk to take that i
that's that's quite quite a bit of to
ask of the taxpayers
uh there is also an independent third
party that would be conducting this
audit but how would that person be
chosen and i think that is another uh
situation that could cause a lot of
turmoil and unhappiness of the people
that we heard testimony from yesterday
if my recent experience is to be a guide
this bill seeks to put into motion the
audit that will
find and explain discrepancies and voter
data ballot data and tabulations
but we
we consider these very serious issues on
this committee and we work very hard to
avoid them
in my own community of derry in 2016
i saw that many state laws were not
being followed and i i addressed them
and in so doing i had to
explain each and every rsa every time i
talked about it
to be accurate enough to affect any
change and
we did have election monitors in derry
in the next election similar to what is
happening in windham in their next
election because of the problems that
they have had now if we could get
perfect people to conduct our elections
we would do so
but in
without having that
we have all of the laws that we have to
address these issues and i hope that we
can do them moving forward
i checked with the secretary of state's
office about any specific complaints in
the days after the election in in
three twenty twenty
if there were any presidential election
um
candidates that that spoke to him about
problems that they had had
and there were none there were no
complaints that came to that office
about that that election and that would
bend the way to address this
appropriately
so i agree with uh secretary scanlon
that
a statewide audit is not necessary and
it would not be the way to address some
of the the serious concerns that we have
about
specifically windham again
and i did read that whole report i was
up late last night i finally got that
report yesterday and i i was up late
reading it but i don't see how this bill
would address all of them moving forward
so for that reason i'm voting itl but
that does not mean i do not care about
the issues that were so passionately
described
yesterday thank you representative
prudhomma brian for that is there
anybody else who wants to speak to this
motion
representative
thank you madam chair
well um
i will be voting uh
in favor of the itl
some uh items were brought up that
um are a little troubling to me
but i don't believe this is the vehicle
to to solve that
um i think going forward we need to look
look forward not look
back
but having said that i may be able to
support uh one of the other bills that
addresses this that does a sample um but
to just spend the time
and
resources and money to
go back and
and and open that back up i don't think
solves anything what i would like to see
us do though is going forward to have
the ability to be able to sample and do
some audits because
in business
audits are something that's done on a
regular basis to ensure that you have
compliance whether they be
errors in you know unintentional errors
or
something worse than that where people
aren't um
following procedure and or
perhaps have a ulterior motive in their
there's some wrongdoing so i think going
forward we know i think all of us in
this room know we have
many citizens in this state
that are concerned about voter integrity
so going forward we do need to in my
restore confidence in the process
thank you
representative barry
i want to kind of echo what
representative trojan said um i have
said in this committee
many many many times in fact i think
literally the first day we met i believe
the number one issue facing this body
is people's lack of faith in the
elections
that comes from a variety of sources
it comes from the windham audit it comes
from things people say elected officials
things that they said
that being said
it is time to look forward
there will be an audit bill that comes
before this body
this body will pass that audit bill we
will have forward-looking audits the
secretary of state
himself stood i believe it was in this
room
and said he supports audits
we have to fix the problem the problem
is the lack of faith in the election i
said it on the
second or third day 33 percent of
granite staters are not extremely
competent in the outcome of a new
hampshire election it's unacceptable
this bill will not solve that problem we
know that from the windham audit this
bill will not solve the lingering
questions of 2022 i don't know if
there's anything that we could do that
would solve those pro that solve those
questions and for my friends on the
other side i don't think there's
anything that we could do to solve the
lingering questions from 2016.
what we can do is come together and find
a forward-looking approach that will
restore people's faith
in these elections
and i'll be supporting the itl for that
purpose
i want to thank the sponsors they are
trying to address
a very legitimate concern the underlying
problem once again is people do not have
faith in the elections i believe firmly
that there will be people that do not
vote because they do not have faith in
the elections and just as my friends on
the other side of the aisle are very
concerned about young people
being being suppressed and and
and all of that i am very concerned
about voter suppression of people who do
not have faith in our process this is
not the way to fix it this is backwards
looking but this body will pass an audit
bill that's forward-looking
thank you
representative growing thank you madam
chair
um i i echo what has been said here and
i would add that
i also believe that this bill does not
have
anywhere near the amount of necessary
uh
detail specificity that's required to
to perform a good quality audit and i
also uh in in just
i think just common sense would say that
it is virtually impossible to complete
such an audit no later than october 1
which again is it is i believe a fatal
i also
firmly support
the concept of having regular and
routine audits on election
on on elections in new hampshire
it amazes me it truly amazes me that we
spend
many many many times as much money
protecting our dollars as we do our
votes and i think that's a travesty and
i think we do need to do this
with my colleague representative
terozian i am
i am interested in pursuing one of the
other bills that would do a
smaller look at the 2020 election but i
don't believe that this bill is is
feasible
uh
to accomplish and certainly doesn't have
the specificity
thank you further comments from
committee members
representative mcdonald
yes madam chairman for all of the
reasons so eloquently stated by my
colleagues i will also be voting itl
further questions or comments
representative bergeron
and i would like to echo representative
mcdonald's comments as well and i will
also be voting itl on this
representative sweeney thank you madam
chair
um i will also be supporting the an
expedient to legislate
i know it's a sense of humor i'll just
remind you all we have a vote and that's
how we find out how you're going to vote
yes yes i
i'm aware i'm prefacing my comments
um our state did have 15 recounts after
the 2020 elections
none of the recounts had any change in
the election night results from who the
winners were versus who the defeated
candidates were
one of them had obviously the big
discrepancy in windham which this
committee took up last year passed an
audit bill and proceeded with the
process that we incorporated all
stakeholders desires
and design for that audit
so
i think we can have faith in the new
hampshire election systems i agree with
what representative barry said and i've
agreed with what what all the members
here have said yesterday during the
committee uh hearing on this bill
my name was
referenced several times by those
testifying
uh in favor of the legislation and i
wanted to take this opportunity to make
it clear
i am no one's puppet i am
here representing the 30 000 roughly
people of salem new hampshire that
constitutes rockingham district 8.
i represent my own views and i vote my
own views
i have not always made anyone happy i
think the chair can attest to
my history of not always going along
with what i have been asked
but that's not why i'm voting itl today
i'm voting itl today
because we did have a number of recounts
after the 2020 election that were a
representative sample i would say of
districts across the state of new
hampshire
and those individual recounts should put
faith in our elections
that we do get it right in new hampshire
and when we when there are towns and
communities that do
make mistakes and have errors we do
correct them uh we corrected and made
sure that wyndham had accurate results
at the end of the day uh we have this
process in bedford now where the state
is investigating as well and i'm sure
we'll be hearing more about that
um and i agree that we should be
forward-looking and not backward-looking
when it comes to the audits that we we
do approve of and create a schedule and
a process for
and i would just urge the entire
committee to to vote with us on an
expedia to legislate thank you
seeing none representative wilhelm
i will also be voting itl in this bill
[Laughter]
all right
we are going to have the vote now on
this bill
1484.
all right i'm going to ask the clerk to
call the roll the the motion on the
floor is itl hb 1484.
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney
yes representative hayward yes
dear representative
yes
representative barry yes
representative growing yes
representative quayley yes
clerk is yes
uh representative wilhelm
representative ward
representative bergeron yes
yes representative hamer yes
representative freitas
yes
representative
yes representative
yes madam chair yes
yes
the the vote is 19-0
yeah
right
um
i think so did you yeah
okay
um
i am probably not going to put this on
the consent calendar because i think
it's going to get pulled
um so with the committee understanding
why i'm not asking for that question
and
the next bill before us today for
executive session is hb 14 90
14 96
do i have a motion
on 14 representative barry did you have
anything on 1496.
yes madam chairman i'm sorry i'm
moving on from the next one um
this 1496 i am asking the committee's
indulgence on a continuance on the bill
um i am working with the um committee
committee just excuse me it's been a
long it was up very late last night the
uh the sponsors uh i am working on an
amendment with the sponsor to try to
reach some kind of compromise language i
think that there is some appetite for
the concept of allowing more access to
the voter checklist than currently
exists
but it needs some tweaking so i'm asking
for a little bit of indulgence in that
because i've been really busy this week
and haven't had to get the amendment
ready
all right i am going to indulge that
request and if any committee member has
a bill that they see an executive
session that they're working with the
sponsor and an amendment and it is not
done
please feel free to bring that forward
keeping in mind and again whip out your
calendars i anticipate that our our last
executive session on bills
before crossover will be the 9th end or
that is the week before our deadline i
want to make sure we have our votes and
reports out in plenty of time but we
there will be bills
um even though we might be ready to do
them they're not going to be scheduled
till after town elections so we're going
to have that opportunity to vote on
anything you might want to continue to
work on on one of those days
all right so 1496 will be re-noticed for
a further
cicr15
lowers the age to vote in a primary to
17 for those who will be 18 in the
general election um i want to make this
comment for this bill and all of the
cacrs you might recall i think it was
done in session that i i made a comment
that the bills app referred to boxes and
check marks when the current practice is
ovals
um i want to thank the sponsors of all
these amendments i emailed them they
contacted ols in regards to changing the
language the secretary of state's office
got involved
and i essentially got told why was i
making a big deal about this because we
passed a cacr two sessions ago and
nobody raised an issue and i'm like
because it wasn't in front of me
um
so the secretary of state's office is
going to work with ols and there will
probably be a change to this these cas
yards or any cacrs for the language
relating to how the ballot is actually
supposed to look
um
because
the ols is saying there's a statute that
says it can be ore and the secretary of
state is saying but the statute is
directing a specific
box and we're going to get that worked
out in enroll bills i will that will not
be considered a substantive amendment to
a bill
so i just wanted to clear that up as to
the cac
ours
um so we have this in front of us and i
believe you should also have a proposed
amendment in front of you amendment 2 20
044h
is there a member who wants to make a
motion
uh yes madam chairman
i would move that we um we move off to
to cacr15 is there a second second that
madam chair
representative barry do you want to
speak to your motion uh yes madam
chairman i would like to um the first of
which madam chairman was recognized this
is a non-german amendment so if we do
take up this amendment we will have to
have
a separate uh hearing on the amendment
the under um if the committee will
indulge me i'll speak to the underlying
bill first and then the amendment
the underlying bill is actually a
concept that i'm not diametrically
opposed to
however this body has rejected it
several times i believe
that the last committee report was
actually written by you madam chairman
as to why it was an expedient to
legislate so when looking at that
the underlying bill was basically a
non-starter it wasn't going to happen
we have had many many many bills
that have attempted to
you know eat around the edges of the
domicile resident question
um and this would be
a bill
a constitutional limit that would
finally solve the question of who gets
to vote in new hampshire
so what it does
is it clarifies that only new hampshire
residents
may vote in new hampshire elections
i believe that this is a debate that
this committee should have i believe it
should be a hearing that this committee
should have and i think it's a vote that
this committee should have
to finally
put that question to bed or at least get
on the record about it it is my firm
belief that only new hampshire residents
should be able to vote that does not
mean college students cannot vote here
that just means residents can vote here
i encourage young people to move here
become residents and vote here
merely showing up on election day and
declaring yourself having a granite
state of mind and casting a ballot
is not a thing in my world
so that's why i brought this amendment
forward it will be a fun debate we might
even have a little bit of it now
but i've thoroughly i hope the committee
passes it and i firmly look forward to
it
further discussion on
the motion
which has been made which is in regards
to
h2 amendment
2022-048 representative bergeron
i'm pleased to have heard representative
berry indicate that this is a
non-germane
amendment
and it is very substantial substantive
as well
um
it it eliminates entirely uh
the original intent of constitutional
amendment 15
which was to allow
um
youth who would be 18 by the general
election to participate in the primary
if they hadn't quite turned 18
you know which is a couple months
earlier the primaries a couple months
earlier uh that's eliminated entirely
and then it introduces the words uh the
person has to be domiciled and have
primary residency
in new hampshire in order to
that is extremely open-ended and
i'm thinking of examples of military who
have the opportunity to declare new
hampshire as their residents if they
entered the service
at the time they were living in new
hampshire they will not be domiciled in
new hampshire any longer and it's really
no longer their primary residency there
are a lot of issues here to to throw
this into the constitution
is a real concern you know we can fight
it out on
among our rsas and change language there
as we do almost every session we have
debates over the subject
but i have real serious concerns about
putting this very restrictive language
into our state constitution and
therefore i will oppose the amendment
and if the amendment passes i will
oppose the bill too
further discussion
representative growing
thank you madam chair
as i campaigned
in the fall of 2020 and as i've talked
to people since
this is one of the
major
issues that i find amongst the voters
that i talk to and i've asked repeatedly
who should vote in new hampshire
and for
the average citizen
who does not
really understand or know the difference
between domicile or residency or what
makes those things up
the automatic answer is a new hampshire
citizen or a new hampshire resident
if i follow that up and ask them what
they mean they say somebody who lives in
new hampshire pays taxes in new
hampshire has their car registered in
new hampshire etc
and
it is it is
almost
exclusively that answer uh and and and
by the way when i'm campaigning
particularly in the last weeks before
the election i do not follow a party
list when i campaign i go door to door
to door to door and talk to everybody
who will come to the door
and i find that answer to come back
again and again
and i think it's just a common sense
approach
that
those who vote in new hampshire should
be vested in new hampshire should should
sort of own new hampshire
i
i understand the concern that
representative bergeron has and we
probably would need to
have further modification to have this
meet that muster but the requirement for
this i believe is very strong and i
think
help voters to be confident that their
further discussion this is as to an
amendment and
representative berry is right it would
be non-germane and require rescheduling
representative muirhead thank you madam
chair i would welcome a chance to really
debate and also inform ourselves of
about all the particulars having to do
with this question which might require a
different bill on a different occasion
so we can learn more about how federal
law
constrains what states do in defining
who can vote in different elections and
so i would welcome that i'm not sure
this is i'm going to to pre-announce i
think i will oppose the passage of this
because i don't think this is giving us
that occasion
thank you representative hayward
i would
address representative bergeron's point
in a simple way
to say that the military is covered
under this would be covered under this
under the federal law
known as the soldiers and sales relief
act
i myself
maintained a
domicile residence
for
an extended period of time i could
get into great detail which i don't
think we need to do today especially if
we're going to
bring this up again but uh it's going to
have to come up the uh
so i'll reserve
that
discussion for anyone who might want it
until later
thank you thank you further discussion
on the motion which is on the floor
which is an amendment
to
cacr15
representative lane
thank you madam chair um
i'm sorry you had your hand up before i
um
i'm sure we will have this debate i
i hate to sound like the lawyer but
after doing it for 40 years i can't help
myself if we're going to do this
we need to define domicile and primary
residency
in here so people know what it is
because this will just invite the court
to go back and we'll be in court again
that's what domicile and residency mean
so if we're going to have this debate
and if we're going to do this
we need to do it so that's clear in here
so that we don't end up back in court
having the same
what it's been 10 15 years now that
we've been going back and forth on this
so
that would be my only
if we could come if this committee could
come up with a solution
as to audits that made everyone happy
and a solution that finally resolved the
domicile residency definition issue
we would have like gold stars are just
falling from the sky
[Laughter]
drinks on the chair
i i will say that i'm not sure that
everyone thought we really did a great
job in windham but that's okay well i i
i no that's very that's very clear
that's why i sort of said that because
as i recall when we did do windham
everybody did thought we did a great job
until
they did the audit in windham all right
so which is often the case and i
understand that so any further
discussion on the motion on the floor
which is the amendment to cacr15 seeing
none i'm going to ask the clerk to call
the role on amendment
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative
yes representative barry yes
representative brown yes
representative
yes
representative bergeron no
representative lane
no representative freitas
no
representative hamlet no representative
the vote is 10 9 the amendment carries
the next bill on so that will be we are
going to
move on from further consideration of
cacr15
it has been amended and a further
hearing will be necessary
the next item on the agenda is cacr 19
this constitutional amendment provides
that all elections shall be conducted
using paper ballots
we had a public hearing on this bill on
january
13th
representative prudhomme o'brien
i move that this ought to pass is there
a second i second the motion madam chair
thank you representative prudhommer
brian would you like to speak to your
motion
uh paper ballots i
provide an opportunity to check and
see what the intent of the voter was
and
for that reason i believe this ought to
pass
exactly
thank you thank you mr chairman and uh
thank you to the committee for just
indulging me as i speak some more um i
am a big fan of this constitutional
amendment i wanted to thank the sponsor
for bringing this forward um as as
representative prudhomme o'brien noted
uh this constitutional amendment is
really fairly simple
it just puts into place what our current
state statute requires for
how we administer our elections
utilizing paper ballots and puts that
into our state's constitution
as we know we change state statute
frequently
in this body
a lot of the legislation that we've
already voted on today does it any
legislation we always vote on we'll
change state statute and there is that
higher threshold to change the state
constitution
by inserting this constitutional
amendment into the constitution in the
present moment that we're in
we will ensure that the state of new
hampshire continues using paper ballots
until such time that the public
overwhelmingly
decides that they no longer want to use
paper ballots as the new constitutional
amendment would have to go through the
process
to me i believe that would effectively
enshrine paper ballots in the state of
new hampshire
for the foreseeable future and i know
i'm not sure would ever be undone
i think it's a system that works as as
the former and it is it is so bizarre to
say former secretary of state bill
gardner uh would famously say you cannot
hack a pencil
in a time when there are so many
questions about other states utilizing
computer forms to fill out ballots and
municipalities in other states
developing tablet systems
for balloting
i think it is paramount that we maintain
a paper ballot for new hampshire
citizens that they fill out
with a with a black sharpie and i want a
shameless plug for everyone listening uh
please fill out the oval completely when
you do vote
because that really does help in
ensuring there's a
accurate count at the end of the night
and for that reasons i would just
recommend everybody vote to pass on this
constitutional amendment i hope we can
get this to the voters this year um and
overwhelmingly i think we would see the
granite state vote in the affirmative so
thank you
thank you representative sweeney anyone
else representative bergeron
thank you
representative mcdonald
i'm going to to oppose this
primarily because i don't think it's
necessary to put this into the
constitution
this is something we can do in the
statutes and in addition the ballot law
commission uh and its
current exercise of trying to find a
replacement machine for
um the accu vote systems which you are
aging
is requiring that paper ballots be used
so we have already two layers of
authority that are requiring paper
ballots we can do it in state law and
the ballot law commission is already
doing it
i see no reason to to put this into the
constitution as well so i'll be opposing
it primarily for that reason
thank you representative bergeron anyone
else
uh yes representative derozan
thank you mr chair
i'll be uh
voting in favor of the motion on the
floor
and again it comes down to
voter integrity and the
belief and rebuilding the confidence
uh
for voters here in the state that we're
ensuring that we don't waver on the idea
of making sure that
we have the ability to audit and if we
get rid of paper ballots
and it's a problem with the machine
either
intentional or otherwise
it's pretty hard to go back and without
a paper trail to ascertain what happens
so it's a pretty simple concept and i
think by putting doing cacr
it codifies it so it's
further discussion the
motion on the floor is cacr19
ought to pass representative growing
thank you madam chair uh
i think it's very important that we put
this in the constitution
this will give us stability a long term
stability as representative sweeney has
mentioned
so that
as we look forward we have a clear
paper
trail record
of our ballots and of our elections
i think our our recount procedure
that we have is one of the reasons why
i believe most people have confidence
in our machine counting
i believe if if it was anything other
than being able to go back and audit by
that it would it would be or or recount
as we're doing now it would be difficult
to do that and i i
as as
technology changes and advances i think
it's very important for us to enshrine
this
in the constitution and if there's a
need to
change at some point down the road
because of technology
our citizens will recognize that and
we'd be able to make that change but for
now i think it's just a very important
process
representative o'brien
thank you madam chair
i just uh wanted to add another
aspect of this
and there was a time when
paper ballots
were not as popular that that the the
idea of modernization
required
the
use of electronic ballot counting
machines without
paper ballots and in other states they
employed that and i i was shocked you
know when i found out
that other states did not use paper
ballots in the same way and
to his credit our former secretary of
state always defended the use of paper
ballots
and then other states
got on board with that as well and have
changed the way they
run their elections to
always include paper ballots i'm
thinking of georgia specifically so
for that reason i think that this
is appropriate to enshrine in our
constitution and it will increase voter
confidence in our elections
and it's not um unnecessary i think it
is necessary that's why i will be voting
not to pass
thank you madam chair um
i recall during the testimony that there
was some debate about whether
ballot meant the actual thing like this
or whether it was these paper receipts
or paper trail
and i thought somebody was going to look
into that but i guess nobody has so it
stands as written
apparently not i don't i don't actually
have that in my notes i know we had a
discussion on it but i didn't have any
of my notes representative barry to
answer representative lane's question i
i that that was my question that i asked
um because we're giving a story about my
parents voting who didn't want to vote
let me go anyways um
the the sponsor's intent was that
it would cover this but the to answer
your question i i mean it could be
ambiguous it was definitely the
legislative intent so maybe by staying
saying this now that that will help that
if that ever comes up if this does
become a constitutional amendment
it's most certainly the legislative
intent because i don't think a receipt
is a ballot it's a receipt it's a paper
trail it's not a ballot
thank you for your comment
representative muirhead
as a
constitutional conservative
um
i don't think we should be amending
constitutions for
trifling reasons or even for reasons
that prove momentary even when they
reflect a very
strong passion
in the moment
i don't think we should be inviting the
public mind to think of constitutions as
things that should be
uh changed frequently
or in the worst case just thrown out
completely we should think of them as
really
sacrosanct and venerable
and only to be amended
for the most
most important reasons and nothing in
the testimony
suggested that there's any organization
or interest
that's opposed to the legislation that
requires paper ballots so in the absence
of really
more urgent reasons
for including this in the constitution i
i would be wary of of doing this so
thank
representative hamlet
thank you madam chair
um
i think uh at some point in the future
it may be way in the future
um we will be
[Music]
um
learning to we'll have a system of
uh doing digital voting as and that we
will learn to trust that as we are now
learning to trust digital currency
so
uh i don't see a reason to put this in
the constitution i know it could be
changed at some point but
it would be a lot harder to change it
out of the constitution
than just changing a law
thank you
thank you representative prudhommer
brian i recently did some crack research
on my phone
uh and by recently i mean in the last
five minutes
uh and the definition of ballot
according to merriam-webster is a sheet
of paper used to cast a secret vote
and i think that is the generally
accepted definition among the public
and
the reason for
why we
believe it's important and our um
accepted definition as well
further comments on the motion on the
floor representative barry i'll be very
brief i just wanted to give
representative hamlet a shout out for
the cryptocurrency reference that was uh
all right we're not talking about
cryptocurrency representative groin
just just uh
to add to what representative prudhomme
o'brien said the the wording in the bill
is for purposes of facilitating the
examination and recounting of votes cast
all elections shall be conducted using
paper ballots so adding to the
definition of ballots that she picked up
uh it says they shall be conducted using
paper ballots i i do think that's very
clear and again i just wanted to add
this
further discussion on the motion on the
floor
which is otp cacr19
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
representative mcdonald
yes representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney
yes
yes yes
do i do that three times
yeah one person one vote
[Music]
yes
representative barry yes
representative growing yes
representative quayley yes
clark is yes
representative ward
representative bergeron
representative murray
no
representative hamer no
represent freitas no
representative hamlet no
representative
no
madam chair yes
oh it's 11 to 9. i'm going to put out
the call on av
over this right again
we are having issues with the
microphones in this room it has now
spread from the three seats in the
center and is now creeping up the back
row
uh if somebody from it can please attend
to the microphone issue oh it's it's it
oh no you put it on and off that wasn't
a flicker um
in room 306 308 that would be
appreciated because i don't think the
mic is picking you all up net when it's
all right so
all right moving on that was cacr19
1009 this is requiring the date a person
registers to vote to be included with
other voted voter information do i have
a motion representative sweeney madam
chair thank you i move ought to pass on
hb one zero zero nine is there a second
yes ma'am chairman i'll second that
representative sweeney would you like to
speak to the motion in your bill yes
thank you madam chair this bill uh is a
very simple piece of legislation um and
i am aware that there are
voter
registered voters that we do not
currently have this data for
but for those that we do have the date
of registration for the date that the
secretary of state received their voter
registration paperwork
they would be able to
put that onto the checklist that they do
manage and and then you know sell to the
political organizations registered in
the state of new hampshire um as just
another data point on the checklist so i
would recom i would encourage everyone
to vote ought to pass thank you further
discussion representative bergeron yes
thank you madam chair uh i'm going to
oppose the the motion of ought to pass
um
this
how to track the information concerns me
for one thing when a person moves let's
say from nashua ward 2 to nashua ward 5
they're considered a new voter in in
ward 5. they may have actually lived in
nashua for 30 years but
this creates a situation where it will
look like they had just registered to
vote maybe two weeks ago
um
i
the idea that this is also going to be
included on the checklist causes me some
concerns there's really no reason for
that um if a person is is coming in to
obtain a checklist what's important is
their their identity and their current
residency their domicile address not
when they registered to vote
this is just
unnecessary
personal information being collected and
displayed on checklists that i think
intrudes upon people's right to privacy
and really serves no purses purpose
whatsoever as to a person's right to get
to get a ballot or not on election day
so i'll be opposing the motion
the bill is hb1009
if there's no
further discussion
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
role
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative alexander yes
representative
yes
representative barry yes representative
growing yes
representative quailey yes
yes representative wilhelm no
representative ward no
representative bergeron no
representative murray
no no
representative hamer no
representative lane
no
representative freitas no
representative hamlet no
no
three notes oh madame chair yes
okay eleven to nine
hb
hb1009 will be reported 11 to 9.
again majority minority reports due to
me by the end close of business monday
the next bill we have scheduled to be
heard this morning is
hb 1010 this had a public hearing on
january 19th and you should have an
amendment in front of you it should have
also been emailed to you 2022
1 1
h uh is there a motion in regards to the
amendment representative sweeney uh
madam chair thank you i move we amend
house bill 1010 fn
um and i'd be willing to speak to my
motion
is there a second second
representative
seconds it
representative sweeney you're recognized
to speak to your motion
thank you thank you madam sharon thank
you to the committee
and i apologize that i was not here on
the january 19th public hearing on this
bill
this bill was the product of
conversations i had with the secretary
of state's office
to just also include in the statewide
voter history
that we that is available to political
organizations the municipal voter
history as well as the state election
voter history that it's collected they
currently do collect the municipal
history
that is available at the secretary of
state's office but is not under statute
available to be included in the voter
history that is sent along with the
voter checklist when that is given to
organizations
so it's not going to create more work on
any departments they already have this
data statute just does not allow this
data to be included in the statewide
voter history file
and this the bill as originally
submitted did not have the right section
amended in law to allow what we had
talked about so the amendment actually
corrects the right section of law
for the intended purpose of the original
bill so thank you
representative bergeron
thank you madam chair um
i support the amendment as proposed by
representative sweeney and
then we'll support the bill as amended i
think this this just happens to be an
odd little
situation of language where i think the
intent was always there that municipal
voter history would be included in
reports it could be provided uh upon
those to those who are eligible to
receive that information um and this i
think just just straightens out the
language to make it clear what the
intent of the original legislation was
so i'll support this
any further discussion on the motion on
the floor which is to move
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll
representative mcdonald
yes
representative tom o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward
represent mooney
oh god sorry representative alexander
whole paper
yeah representative tarosian yes
representative barry yes representative
growing yes
representative quailey yes
yes
um representative
wilhelm
representative ward
representative bergeron yes
representative hamer yes
representative lane
yes representative freitas yes
representative hamlet yes
yes madam chair yes
the amendment
carries 20 to zero hb 1010 is now
amended is there a motion
representative sweeney thank you madam
chair i move uh ought to pass as amended
on house bill 1010. representative
is there any further discussion on the
motion which is on the floor
bergeron are you just on or did you want
to speak
thank you
representative
did you want to speak
i'm all set thank you okay thank you
i just finally got the mic back so i
figured i'd leave it on in case i need
it all right just be very quiet
representative mcdonald are you all set
okay
all right seeing no discussion i'm going
to ask the clerk to call the role the
motion on the floor is uh
hb 1010 ought to pass as amended
amendment 2022-113
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative alexander yes
representation yes representative barry
yes
representative growing yes
representative quailey
clark is yes representative wilhelm yes
representative
representative bergeron yes
representative murray yeah
representative hamer yes representative
lane
represent freitas yes representative
hamblet
representative
madam chair yes
all right without objection i'm going to
put that one on the consent calendar
let's see
all right so that will go on the consent
calendar
uh the next bill we have us before it
says 1442.
um this is in regards to the
setting a new requirement for the
printing of multiple languages in
regards to
election material
we had presented by the sponsor an
amendment
on it
and i have had a request to possibly do
study on this particular
uh bill given
we're going to have a discussion on
whether we have a study on this so
representative moorhead
could you explain a little bit about
what path you see forward for 1442
during the
thank you madam chair during the
testimony a variety of
specific questions were raised about the
bill having to do with a number of
languages spoken different places the
incidents in which they're spoken
the kinds of regulations that the voting
rights act places on states and federal
legislation and uh and and i think more
questions are raised than answered
and it might uh it might help this
committee deliberate on on the bill to
uh to
be able to commit this to further study
and consider some of those questions at
anybody want to speak on this
representative bergeron yes thank you
madam chair um and and i
support representative murrah's
suggestion the uh help america vote act
um
contains provisions on when voting
materials need to be provided in um
second or third languages and and
there's thresholds that have to be met
uh for example five percent if
uh the voting age citizens are limited
english proficient or if their education
levels are at
fifth grade levels um
if
if we were to do something like this and
certainly the bill as it's currently
written probably doesn't isn't clear
enough uh i think it would be
important for us to understand how new
hampshire may eventually have to
incorporate some of these federal
requirements on
language proficiency in terms of voting
activity i i think we could learn a lot
from an interim study exercise and
i don't think we would produce
legislation but i think it would prepare
us for
action on something like this perhaps in
i
i have to tell you at as chair the
situation i created for us as a
committee with the number of retained
bills last year was
um
something i would not knowingly do again
um and so i guess what uh
i would have been looking for
was some specifics raised
in regards to the bill itself rather
than
the requirement i'm i'm not
sure that i'm really hearing anything
other than this is a pretty interesting
and complex area of the law
and maybe we should look at it
some more but i'm not hearing
what different outcome people white
might want which is why we have
amendments and i am always happy to
entertain amendments
so could could
you know i get we get staff to help us
study an issue
um
if we
hold on to bills but i'm not sure
where we're trying to end up on this if
anybody have any clarification for that
um i appreciate your uh you know your
your
reflections on on
on retaining bills and as a as a you
know beginner uh
i have a lot to learn but i i thought
there might be some
maybe more than some utility to to
retaining this uh nonetheless i you know
defer to your expertise madam chair
it has nothing to do with expertise that
has to do with calendars and votings and
um
where we're going to end up
we did have an amendment in regards to
this that was presented
and spoken to when i i guess what i
would like to do is to get that
on the floor is there anybody who wants
to move
representative barry
uh yes madam chairman i will move as a
courtesy to the sponsor that we adopt
amendment
2022-016-h
is there a second madam chair
okay we have seconds all over the place
it's on the floor
um
does anybody want to speak to this
amendment
anybody want to speak and recap what the
sponsor presented in regards to the
amendment representative bergeron thank
you madam chair um
one of the issues that we had when the
sponsor initially presented the bill was
it wasn't really clear how many
languages voter materials would need to
be made
available and i think was pointed out
that some of our cities have as many as
52 to 54 languages spoken in their
school systems
in addition
there
wasn't a clear threshold of what
percentage of people would be
primarily
their prime language was other some
language other than english so the
sponsor tried to address that by saying
the threshold was three percent and then
he included language that says up to
three languages uh as opposed to concern
some of us might have had for how many
languages are actually spoken in our
communities
thank you
seeing none i'm going to ask the chair
to excuse me the clerk to call the role
for the amendment
representative o'brien
yes
representative sweeney
representative hayward
representative alexander yes
representative
yes
representative barry yes representative
growing yes representative
yes clerk is yes representative wilhelm
representative bergeron
yes
representative murray
representative hamer yes representative
lane represent freitas yes
representative hamblet
representative your head yes
so it's 19 to 1.
i'm adam chairman
representative mcdonald i'd like to
switch my vote to uh yes i didn't hear
the clerk announce the total so that's
fine what's the new total with
representative mcdonnell changing his
vote
hb 1442 is before the committee on the
amendment so
um
i think maybe we can incorporate
comments on the amendment and
representative meurer had comments is
there
to what's on the floor at the present
time
i'm sorry was a motion made to act on
this bill as amended yet no
would it be appropriate for me to move
uh that this bill should be ought to
pass as amended
sure i'll take that motion okay i will
so move i'd like to speak on the motion
if i might
a second
okay i slipped up by letting that happen
you guys need to be a little bit more on
thank you madam chair all right
representative bergeron to speak to your
motion while the bill is amended perhaps
lacks the kind of
precision and the uh
types of measurements that should be
used in determining which languages a
community might choose to
make voter information available in it
is a step in the right direction and
therefore i would support the bill as
amended
representative sweeney
madam chair thank you um while i i agree
that we have amended the bill um and i
supported as the roll call says that
move to amend um i will be voting
against this motion
i just do not feel that this legislation
is ready for prime time and i i believe
and agree with others that have stated
the calendar constraints of the cycle
really do not pertain us to do too much
else with this legislation
but i will not be supporting octopass as
amended thank you
i i'll just say for experience for
representative moorhead what
the leadership has done in this
particular calendar cycle is once again
decide it would be very nice to get
everything done in may
and not be in session in june
which sounds wonderful when you're
setting the calendar in the first week
in january but when you get to april
it's a really horrible idea so i'll just
say that from experience representative
i
needs of people who are not
fluent in english but when i asked the
sponsor about this bill he was not able
to tell me the amount of people in his
community of nashua who
were the percentage of people that were
not
able to
speak fluently in english so i'm not
sure how much of a problem there is
and for that reason i i will be voting
against the ought to pass as amended
representative barry yes madam chairman
i'll be uh just renouncing our votes
i'll be uh voting against the uh the
motion of ought to pass as amended um
the uh i believe the idea of an interim
study was was thrown about uh but it
doesn't seem like that's the path we'll
be going forward so i would ask the
committee to vote
against the ought to pass as admitted
motion so that another emotion can be
brought forward
any further discussion on the motion
which is ought to pass as amended
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the role representative mcdonald
no
representative prudhomme o'brien no
representative sweeney no
representative hayward no
representative alexander no
representative
no
representative growing no
representative
no
representative wilhelm yes
representative ward yes
represent bergeron
representative murray
yes
representative hamer yes
representative lane yes represent
freitas yes representative hamlet yes
represent
nine to eleven is there anyone the
motion is on that the bill is on the
floor is amended is there a further
motion representative barry uh yes madam
chairman i would like to move that hb 14
42 fn is amended uh be inexpedient to
legislate is there a second yes madam
chair i will second that peter hayward's
if representative hayward seconds it is
there further discussion on the motion
on the floor which is to an itl
on
hb
as amended
scene i'm going to ask the clerk to call
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward
representative moon uh representative
alexander
alexander tarosian
yeah okay representative terossian
yes
representative barry yes representative
growing yes representative quali yes
clerk is yes
representative wilhelm
representative ward
representative bergeron no
representative hamer no
representative blaine
no
excuse me no representative freitas no
representative
1442 will be uh reported as
itl
and i'm gonna look for a minority report
and i'm assuming that's the amendment
that would go in the calendar but you
can
talk about that the last bill we have
scheduled for executive session this
morning is hb 1157. this is relative to
electronic ballot counting devices
and this bill would prohibit electronic
ballot accounting devices from being
connected to the
internet
do i have a motion representative teresa
thank you madam chair i uh make a motion
to auto pass for house bill 1157 is
there a second i second that motion
madam chair
thank you hb 1157 is on the floor with
the motion of ought to pass would you
like to speak to your motion
representative terozian yes please madam
chair
so um
as i think we all know in here we've
heard um testimony i've gotten numerous
emails about the concern for voter
integrity
in the state
it's also no secret that
many towns are looking at replacing
their
current vote counting machines as they
get to the end of their life
so with that in mind with with the idea
that um
connecting these machines to the
internet
could lend itself to problems
of being hacked
either intentionally or otherwise
this is a common sense
bill to ensure that we never connect
them because i can't think any good
reason to to connect these
and give anybody temptation to try to
see if they can get in and and tamper
with them
so with with
with that being said
in the name of
increasing
uh confidence
in voter
in voter integrity in the state of new
hampshire
i hope you join me to vote in support of
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair
i'll be supporting the bill as well um
i was not present for the public hearing
so i reached out to secretary scanlon
with a couple of questions that i had
one dealt specifically with the
accessible voting system i was wondering
if that used any kind of wi-fi or
internet
technology he advised me that it's
hardwired and does not have wireless
capability
i also asked him uh if any of the
machines being looked at currently to
replace the accu volt machine had
wireless capability and he said no the
ballot law commission has established
that the devices should not have
wireless capabilities so i was satisfied
with my questions and and i agree with
the previous speaker that this this
really
it doesn't hurt to put it into the
statute and say that it shall not have
wireless capability
further discussion on the motion on the
floor which is otp hb
1157.
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien
yes
representative sweeney
representative hayward
representative alexander yes
representative
yes representative barry yes
representative growing yes
representative quailey yes
yes representative wilhelm yes
representative bergeron yes
representative murray yes
representative hamer yes representative
lane
representative freitas yes
representative hamlet yes
representative your head yes
madam
yes
the vote is 20 to zero it will go on the
consent calendar
with no objection that concludes our
executive session business today we've
had a couple of bills continue to a
further date
um again uh we will be meeting again
next thursday for both public hearings
and executive session reports on the
bills exec today are due to me by close
of business on monday
and expect them to be in the calendar
for our session the following week will
which will be at a minimum on the 17th
possibly on the afternoon of the 16th so
thank you very much everybody have a
pleasant rest of your day
and
you